during the campaign Donald Trump talked
a lot about he how he was going to just
get so much done on his first day his
first week his first hundred days in
office and yesterday I played a clip for
you of Donald Trump's unhinged 31 year
old advisor Stephen Miller who went on
the Sunday morning shows over the
weekend and gave these very
authoritarian kim jongwan style
proclamation saying among other things
we have a president who has done more in
three weeks than most presidents have
done in an entire administration and
that got me thinking wait a second
usually the truth is the opposite of
what Trump's advisers say what has
Donald Trump accomplished so far other
than signing orders that he likely
didn't read what is he actually done
that it has that has had a real-world
and P Racal impact and Trump's strongest
critics say he's dismantling America his
supporters say he's getting a lot done
by following through with campaign
promises the truth is that neither in
the case that is the case
Donald Trump has signed 45 executive
orders and memos first of all this is
actually fewer than the number President
Obama had signed at this point in his
presidency but I want to focus on
content rather than quantity none of the
executive orders that Trump has signed
actually create actions or changes
except for the Muslim majority country
immigration ban which you'll remember
was actually struck down by an appeal
school by Washington Court an appeals
court and eventually the 9th Circuit
Court and is now no it's dead it's like
it never happened
most of trumps executive orders have
been signed with great theater in the
Oval Office but they're just sort of
grandiose suggestions for the government
to do things which it placates the
trumpets but the execution of these
orders actually requires some
combination of approval and funding from
Congress it's mostly song and dance one
example is the Keystone and Dakota
access pipeline orders Trump sign these
orders directing the federal government
to stop impeding infrastructure projects
but that has no legal bearing on the
responsibilities of the Army Corps of
Engineers which actually decides about
Dakota access pipeline Keystone XL it's
horrible don't get me wrong that the
is trying to get these pipelines going
because it's the laughingstock of the
modern world the president supporting it
still could have an impact but again it
does nothing in the short term
another example Trump signed a crime
executive order on February 9th it was
meant to quote prevent violence against
law enforcement officers and combat
transnational criminal organizations
sounds great right I mean who would be
opposed to that but again it doesn't
change any policies Donald Trump's
orders on health care
Isis growing the military they had no
legal weight
recall that the Obama care ordered that
Donald Trump signed very early on it was
like day two maybe of his presidency
Obamacare is still in place and by the
way the repeal effort for Obamacare has
slowed way down again these are
suggestions the idea that the president
would like these things to happen and
when you talk about the smallest most
efficient government possible a
conservative small government idea some
of trumps orders have just been
straight-up redundant on January 25th
the order to crack down on undocumented
immigration it didn't suggest anything
different from Bush and Obama era
policies it was just nonsense language
the border wall order it doesn't
actually do anything Congress already
passed in 2006 the secure Fence Act
which essentially called for the same
thing it did nothing what it did do was
completed during the Bush and Obama
administrations and as we know with
deportations Donald Trump is likely
going to deport fewer people than were
deported under the Barack Obama
administration so Trump has signed a lot
of stuff that he probably didn't read
but he's barely done a thing so far but
I think there's at least the appearance
that he's done a lot because a few
things that he has done has been rolled
out so poorly that there's this media
circus that follows it and his
spokespeople get in trouble for saying
all this crazy stuff afterwards yes so I
mean like with regards to the refugee
and immigration ban yes so I mean with
that even though it has since been
nullified I mean the the effects of that
are long-lasting and that was heard
around the world so there was a big deal
of attention paid to that
oh yeah there's certainly like a PR
effect and the opinion of countries
around the world of the
and temporarily there were many many
people that were delayed it's stuck at
airports etc but in terms of lasting
American policy it accomplished nothing
and the list of broken campaign promises
from Trump is getting longer and longer
he wanted to at one point ban all Muslim
immigrants he's changed that to this
more selective ban which itself was
blocked by a Washington Court appeals
court and then the Ninth Circuit Court
the beginning of an Obamacare repeal on
day one again he signed an executive
order which actually didn't do anything
he now says he likes portions of the
Affordable Care Act and no repeal has
actually started the entire build a wall
with Mexico and make them pay for it I
mean that's laughable we know that
that's not going to happen as described
it would actually cost twenty two
billion dollars and would likely not
even be done by Donald Trump's by the
end of Trump's first term investigated
Hillary Clinton fell apart never
actually really planned to do that the
Supreme Court appointments that would
reverse national gay marriage now he
says he's fine with that stopped job
outsourcing there's been no nationwide
reduction of jobs leaving the u.s. he
saved some carrier and four jobs by
making one-off deals which don't
represent policy so what Trump says and
Saten signals as Pat said matters but we
can't go forward thinking that Donald
Trump has really done anything in these
first three weeks because it's been
basically signaling and signing stuff
that doesn't really change anything you
know it's interesting I mean there used
to be this unwritten rule in politics
where you don't criticize a president in
the first 100 days because that's been
the spirit of giving him a chance with
all the craziness that he's done yeah
there's no way that you could pay
attention to that rule now he's had more
scandals in the first twenty five days
than President Obama had in eight years
yeah the idea of oh we're not going to
criticize for a hundred days it seems
completely laughable at this point